giscard et schmitt s'adresse à moscou et
à washington
l'essence augmente de 7 centimes
philippe ça s'ils avaient raison
pour comprendre le tchad un reportage de
françois corner vacances les départs
augmente la bousculade commence mais à
messieurs bonsoir pour voir ce journal
nous pouvions parler de la hausse du
prix naissance des embouteillages dans
les stations de sports d'hiver ou bien
encore du sommet franco allemand
mais lorsqu'il ya deux heures nous sont
arrivées ces images en provenance
d'ethiopie notre choix devenait
impératif ces images ne sont pourtant
pas récente elle vienne d'ethiopie mais
on ne parle jamais de l'ethiopie déchiré
par la guerre depuis de longues années
les journalistes avec difficulté mais
quand ils réussissent à y pénétrer
regardez ce qu'ils découvrent la famine
pire encore peut-être en ouganda
on a tout dit ou presque tout vu ou
presque de ses misères qui nous concerne
que de loin nos sociétés nanties
indifférence pour certains irritation
pour d'autres sentiments d'impuissance
pour beaucoup pourtant devant de telles
images
c'est notre dignité d'homme qui est
attaque la loi du progrès passe aussi
par les premières nécessités de l'être
humain dont 850 millions d'hommes ne
bénéficient pas dans certains pays on
parle de surproduction alimentaire dans
d'autres le problème est de manger
chaque jour
ces images ont été tournées en ethiopie
à différentes époques mais elles sont
toujours d'actualité la famine touche
surtout les basses plaines
ici quand il n'y a pas d'eau n'y a pas
de récolte les enfants comme toujours
sont les premières victimes
difficile de ne pas être ému comme m
pierre force quand on voit donc ses
images il faut savoir aussi qu en
ouganda
ça continue à nouveau une polémique en
ouganda sur les secours et sur
l'acheminement des approvisionnements
dans le nord du pays aux carmausins fin
du sommet franco-allemand de ce que le
président français a appelé un
anniversaire de famille difficile de
voir des nuages entre les deux capitales
alors au delà des hommes
visiblement connivence des politiques
paris et bonn entendent plus que jamais
avoir une action commune face à la
situation internationale
les deux capitales ont réaffirmé la
condamnation de l'intervention
soviétique en afghanistan et souhaite
que l'on recherche des solutions
politiques partout dans le monde par
exemple au proche orient ou en afrique
et dans une déclaration commune
messieurs schmitt et giscard d'estaing
ont mentionné trois exigences pour
stabiliser la les relations est-ouest et
sauvegarder la paix exigences d'abord d'
équilibre dans la sécurité ou nous
insistons sur l' équilibre global des
forces en excluant à la fois
l'acceptation d'une situation de
faiblesse et la recherche d'une
supériorité militaire exigences ensuite
de modération des comportements
politiques
nous soulignons à cet égard qu'il est
essentiel que la pologne puisse résoudre
ses graves problèmes elle même d'une
manière pacifique et sans ingérence
extérieure
la troisième exigence et celle de
l'égalité dans les responsabilités face
aux grands problèmes du monde
problème du développement et du
sous-développement problème de l' usage
pacifique de l'énergie nucléaire
problème delà du retour à la stabilité
économique et monétaire dans le monde
grâce notamment à une évolution plus
modérée des prix du pétrole
c'est que nous avons en couvert ce mr
collaboration est là zds la raison pour
laquelle michel meyer comme petter sur
la tour sont là d'abord vous et c'est le
meilleur il faut revenir sur ces trois
points
tout d'abord équipe de la sécurité vient
l'idée de base est que les deux grands
ne doivent pas maintenant faire de
surenchère en matière d'armement
militaire et de réarmement militaire
l'objectif doit être l'équilibré entre
les deux grandes puissances de façon à
ce que
on ne débouche pas sur une espèce de
dérapages qui serait de toute façon
suicidaire à terme à travers la relance
des armements
deuxième thème modération retenu retenu
on n'en parle plus en plus dans l'âme il
ya là un appel très claire la non
intervention en pologne et cela
s'adresse bien entendu à l'union
soviétique
d'autant qu'il a été rappelé que la
détente on dirait maintenant la
stabilité ou l' équilibre dans la bouche
de monsieur schmitt et bien cet
équilibre ne résisterait pas un nouveau
coup type afghanistan
enfin égalité des responsabilités alors
là appel à la raison pour que l'on cesse
autant à moscou qu'à washington de se
limiter d'être obsédé en permanence par
les conflits et les tensions est-ouest
et que l'on pense un peu plus à ceux qui
meurent de faim plus au sud à ceux qui
vont se révolter plus au sud
il y a là une espèce de d'appels à une
prise de conscience que ce monde est en
train de devenir très petit et qu'en
définitive européen soviétique america
développer ou sous développés sont les
passagers du même vaisseau terre voici
donc en résumé ces trois exigences trois
exigences qui ont été l'essentiel de ses
sommets mais pas tous ce sommet des
grosses sommes aof gab meine les bosses
à l'entente franco-allemande a été la
plus grande taille de ma vie c'est en
citant le poète allemand heinrich heine
que valéry giscard d'estaing a clos un
sommet où le rapprochement culturel
entre les deux peuples a également tenu
un rôle central malgré les circonstances
internationales otan helmut schmidt que
valéry giscard d'estaing estime en effet
que français et allemands se connaissent
encore mal des efforts seront donc faits
sous l'impulsion des états ou
intensifiée l'enseignement du français
en allemagne et réciproquement
sur le plan scientifique même
intensification des efforts avec
notamment la création à paris d'un
institut sur l'allemagne moderne
en attendant helmut schmidt a visité au
musée d'art moderne de paris une
exposition sur l'art allemand
contemporain
un acte symbolique pour conclure une
rencontre qui veut élargir et
populariser une entente
qui se situe encore trop haut niveau des
deux gouvernements
à cet égard selmou schmidt a fait pour
antenne 2 et ap taffel la tour le bilan
de sept ans de coopération étroite avec
le président français s'étend sur la
même longueur d'onde nous dit il nous
sommes convaincus que sans ces rapports
nous ne pourrions pas assuré avec succès
notre politique étrangère respectives
ce n'est pas dirigée contre les états
unis et contre personne d'ailleurs même
pas contre l'union soviétique et les
pays de l'est
nous croyons seulement qu'en raison de
l'existence de deux supers pouvoirs très
puissant il ne serait pas possible de
faire entendre autrement qu ensemble
notre point de vue en bêta sur la tour 2
avec nos vues de bonnes comment est-ce
qu'on jugera demain ce sommet je crois
que les cassandre ont eu tort sur ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils avaient un
refroidissement dans les relations
franco allemandes et notamment entre le
président français le socialement ont
certainement eu tort il y avait une très
très grande cordialité je crois piel une
entente presque sur tous les points
il ya une situation qui a changé quand
même depuis l'an dernier
l'an dernier j'avais déjà l'afghanistan
à ça reste les positions restent
identiques mais maintenant il ya la
pologne si c'est la grande préoccupation
on veut bien maintenir l'ordre
d'helsinki mais on commence à se
demander c'est lors de yalta n'est pas
notre finalement un peu dépassée alors
qu'ils sont tout à fait exception la
tour coïncidence peut être les amis de
helmut schmidt ont profité de ce sommet
pour adresser un soutien c'est
chaleureux à françois mitterrand pour
les prochaines heures puis je me suis
renseigné en fait il semble que le
chancelier par l'ancien chancelier
prends tu n'as pas été participant à
cette action là et au fond c'est un
assez mauvais coups qu'on a porté chance
et il en est conscient il ya une aile de
son propre parti qui le gêne
d'abord sur le plan de l'énergie
nucléaire dans les questions d'armement
et les rapports avec l'amérique et
maintenant ça se transporte également
sur le plan franco allemand je crois
qu'il a très mal pris la chose
chacun son candidat on peut dire que
giscard est un pull col de la chemise
jeu dans les jambes je crois qu'il
faudra pas faire de noeux propagande
électorale mais enfin elle pencherait
vers faire giscardisme seulement le
il conçoit parfaitement son parti a le
droit d'être favorable candidat
socialiste en france selon pas de cette
façon et y'a pas à ce moment-là voit les
deux amants beaucoup évoqué les
nouvelles orientations de washington
nous l'avons dit visiblement il ne
souhaite pas laisser à ronald reagan le
devant de la scène internationale en
matière d'initiative on à l'organe qui
cette nuit a exposé les grandes lignes
de son programme économique avec
notamment réduction des dépenses de
pratiquement tous les ministères
réduction de 10% de l'impôt sur le
revenu etc et vous le voyez ronald
reagan a utilisé un dollar et quelques
pièces de monnaie ainsi que des tableaux
et des courbes pour essayer de mieux
faire comprendre sa nouvelle politique
économique
monsieur regan qui fêtait aujourd'hui
son 70e anniversaire à washington comme
à paris comme à bonn c'est toujours vers
la pologne on l'a dit que se concentrent
l'attention
la pologne où l'on ce soir une certaine
détente le travail reprendra en effet
demain puisque au viala dans le sud du
pays et lech walesa a annulé son mot
d'ordre de préparation à la grève
une fois de plus on est passé à côté de
la crise après escalade des derniers
jours et notamment l'appel lancé
mercredi dernier par lech walesa peau
une occupation éventuelle des usines
dans le sud du pays si les autorités
utiliser la force
et puis la faire c'est comme l'on dit
dégonfler le climat est selon un mot
consacré à la dédramatisation dans les
rues de varsovie la capitale on éprouve
une fois de plus ce sentiment de
curieuses équilibre pour un pays du bloc
socialiste un pays où les gens
commencent à prendre l'habitude de voir
les inscriptions du syndicat solidarité
à côté des affiches officielles un pays
où soudain sur un mot d'ordre les
ouvriers débrayent les magasins se
ferment tout un ensemble qui tisse une
toile de fond ou la menace de
l'intervention soviétique reste malgré
tout toujours présente dans un coin du
décor
j'ajoute que l'ancien premier ministre
polonais monsieur rocchi vite ça a été
exclue partie on lui reprochait d'avoir
lancé une conception il réfléchit deux
changements de prix il ya quatre ans de
s'être rendue coupable d' autoritarisme
et d'avoir négligé les critiques
centrafrique la constitution adoptée à
une très faible majorité
et puis rend les quatre britanniques
encore détenus à teyran vont bientôt
être libéré a dit monsieur bani sadr
mais pour l'instant en iran l'essentiel
n'est pas là l'essentiel c'est que l'on
vient d'apprendre que le gouvernement
français était prêt à livrer à l'iran
les trois vedettes lance-missiles bloqué
à chabot trois vedettes trois vedettes
seulement mais trois vedettes
lance-missiles le dernier cri des
arsenaux français le gouvernement
iranien qui attend leurs livraisons
s'irrite de voir que ses adversaires les
irakiens eux ont reçu livraison de
mirage français
réponse française il ne s'agit pas d'un
embargo politique car la france a pour
principe d'honorer les contrats déjà
signés
mais les iraniens la suite de la
révolution ont dénoncé eu beaucoup de
causes financières qu'il est lié à
l'industrie française
si les modalités financières en question
sont réglés et bien la france livrera
les vedettes de cherbourg et entre paris
et téhéran cette entente financière
ressemblera beaucoup à une détente
politique en france tout est lié
première régulation la hausse du prix
des sens elle coïncide avec les départs
massifs dont nous allons parler tout à
l'heure
comme l'avait dit philippe ceci
avant-hier c'est bien de 7 centimes
qu'augmentera l'essence à minuit sept
centimes c'est à dire beaucoup moins que
ce qui était prévu au départ ans
s'étonne un petit peu le gouvernement a
donc choisi de ne pas répercuter
l'envolée du cours du dollar sur le prix
de l'essence il l'avait fait votre
pompiste vous aurez comptait encore 7
centimes supplémentaires par litre au
moins et la hausse aurait donc été de
l'ordre de 15 centimes
pourquoi cette modération alors que le
gouvernement a toujours affirmé
nous devons répercuter les hausses cette
sagesse peu habituelle s'explique par un
espoir et par un pari l'espoir est bien
c'est que le dollar qui a pris le galop
avec monsieur reggane se remette au pas
et que la manière
week-end retrouve un cours un peu plus
raisonnable le pari c'est que le prix du
pétrole reste assez sage dans les mois
qui viennent certains producteurs comme
les émirats arabes unis souhaitent en
effet un gel des prix en 1981 et ce
n'est pas avant le mois de mai que
l'opep doit se réunit une augmentation
trop forte de l'essence aurait par
ailleurs donné un accès de fièvre à l'
indice des prix de février qui sera
connu vers le 25 mars prochain en pleine
période électorale
or beaucoup d'experts estiment qu'il est
injuste de juger l'inflation française à
travers les chocs pétroliers et le
gouvernement pense donc qu'on peut
étaler et atténuer la hausse cette fois
ci les compagnies pétrolières pour qui
être de leur poche mais si le dollar
conserve dans sa partie de bras de fer
avec les monnaies occidentales la forme
du fameux marin popeye est bien pour les
automobilistes
ce ne sera qu'un répit arrière donc les
prix du jambon et de certaines
catégories de chambres d'hôtel ont été
libérés c'est donc en pleine vague de
départs qu'on a appris cette
augmentation des parts par la route
ousmane faire avec ce que vous pouvez
imaginer l'embouteillage dû à une
mauvaise coordination des congés
scolaires cette année et dans le règne
de l'improvisation et bien les
débrouillards sont les rois
bernard marck et y en a trop bien bison
futé prévoit des embouteillages monstres
dès demain à partir de 4h sur les routes
de la neige et recommande de ne pas
partir avant 10 heures mais il y a plus
futés encore que ce bison là ce sont les
vacanciers qui ont réussi à anticiper
d'une demi-journée sur les grandes et
par exemple la famille baylet de
bry-sur-marne la petite muriel a été
cueilli à milliers à la sortie de
l'école par son père elle manquera aux
classes de l'après midi et c'est une
pratique assez courante l'éveil de congé
12h15 tout est paré ont des jeunes rats
en roulant de quelques sandwichs
ras
le formel vous avez choisi un itinéraire
ou savait que les embouteillages prévu
oui c'est pour ça que je parle un peu
plus tôt et je vais prendre l'autoroute
jusqu'à orléans et après je prends la
nationale 1b ici pour sortir de la
région parisienne
rien pour sortir je vais passer sur
champigny je rattrape le carrefour
pompadour créteil selon jean relie et
puis je rattrape penser que c'est un bon
choix vous êtes fier aux informations de
la radio ce matin
ce matin quand j'ai pas bien écouté sa
formation mais enfin je pense qu'à cette
heure ci ne doit pas avoir trop de
problèmes pour sortir le pari alors
bonne route
merci beaucoup
un itinéraire astucieux pour sortir de
la région parisienne et sur l'autoroute
et bien le trafic est très fluide comme
diraient les spécialistes
pour les pelles et le tour est joué ils
arriveront à la montagne sans crises
nerveuses
ceux qui auront été moins prévoyants
s'en repentir on en voici la preuve à
césaire l'autoroute du sud donne déjà à
flins or le nombre des départs dans la
région parisienne augmentera de 3% par
rapport à l'année dernière sur
l'ensemble du pays
huit académies sur 27 ont libéré ce soir
leurs trois millions sept cent mille
élèves en même temps notamment les trois
académies qui représente 40% de la
population scolaire paris créteil et
versailles
autre aspect du jour ' à la gare de lyon
451 train aujourd'hui et plus de 1000 en
tout pendant le week end conduiront à la
neige plus d'un million de personnes
c'est l'échec du fameux étalement des
vacances espoirs ultime et 20 et
responsables de stations de montagne qui
seront demain débordé alors que dans dix
jours les hôtels seront à moitié vide
les deux attentats d'hier soir à paris
sur les champs elysées contre air france
et la twr ont été revendiqués par le
mouvement nationaliste arménien 3
octobre
et puis les intégristes l'union pour la
fidélité ont protesté aujourd'hui contre
la nomination du nouvel archevêque de
paris il est bien connue et utilisée
pour ses opinions progressistes et
révolutionnaires
alors tout ça nous fait un petit peu
dérapé sur la politique avec les
traditionnelles sondages il y en a dans
l'express nous la peur et dans le figaro
magazine
celui ci donne la côte du prévôt
république qu'il est au plus bas 44%
confiance en lui 51% ne lui font plus
confiance
autre sondage celui de la croix sur les
catholiques et la politique il fait
apparaître vous voyez au premier tour
au second tour la majorité des
pratiquants réguliers votera giscard les
non-pratiquants plutôt mitterrand au
premier tour et bien en tête valéry
giscard d'estaing devant michel debré
jacques chirac et françois mitterrand
la politique c'est aussi la préparation
du congrès extraordinaire du rpr demain
marie france garaud le récuse à l'avancé
n'autorise personne à présenter sa
candidature et a fortiori a procédé sur
son nom un simulacre de vote qui la
cites
olivier guichard de son côté ne
participera pas à ce congrès monsieur
guichard qui soutiendra michel debré il
ne sera pas là non plus enfin autre
absent jacques chirac qui sera lui dans
son fief du sel
georges marchais lance trois défis au
chef de l'état justice sociale progrès
et démocratie
il était aujourd'hui à saint fons dans
la banlieue lyonnaise le pc qualifie par
ailleurs d' intolérable
l'augmentation des carburants la sphère
bidal ouf les demande de révocation de
deux membres du conseil de la
magistrature sont rejetés et puis la
mort du professeur philippe maupas s'il
l'avait été grièvement blessé dans un
accident de la route dimanche c'était le
doyen de la faculté de pharmacie de
tours et c'est lui qui a mis
au point le vaccin contre l'hépatite
virale b enfin la disparition de l'un de
nos confrères l'un de ceux qui nous a
apporté le plus du moins tous ceux qui
l'ont côtoyé roger michaud elle fait
partie
une très grande partie de sa carrière à
lower tier essentiellement à france
inter il avait fondé le syndicat des
journalistes force ouvrière c'était un
homme d'une exceptionnelle qualité
humaine
voici donc l'heure de notre dossier
ce soir le tchad le tchad à nouveau
déchirée ne sont plus les rudes combats
que l'on avait connu le mois dernier
n'djamena mais ce pourrait bien être une
future guerre de cesse de sédation en
gros je schématise le nord beyer
goukouni prêt à s'allier avec la libye a
fusionné même et puis de l'autre le sud
avec kamougué numéro deux du régime il
très vraisemblable que robert galley le
ministre français de la défense qui
vient d'arriver aujourd'hui au gabon le
rencontre là bas il aurait les faveurs
de la france le reportage au tchad de
françois cornet et dallas 1 les rues de
la capitale tchadienne garderont
longtemps les traces des combats que se
sont livrée ici pendant des mois les
rebelles dit senna bré les forces de
coalition dame à tabac de koungou niue
day et du colonel kamougué ci n djamena
n'est plus en guerre depuis le 14
décembre
elle est loin d'être aujourd'hui en paix
une atmosphère lourde règne sur la ville
en ruines
les conséquences économiques de la
guerre civile sont catastrophiques
le coeur administratif et commercial
entièrement dévastés et surtout cela
vient se greffer un autre problème peut
être encore plus important celui de la
présence libyenne
l'armée du colonel kadhafi et maintenant
sérieusement implantée dans la zone des
djamena jeu il est très difficile
d'estimer
le nombre de défauts de délits bien ici
mais on peut estimer qu'ils sont quand
même au nombre de 3000 à 3500 avec de
l'armement lourd et des mig 21 mai les
mig-21 vous êtes sur le terrain
de quoi ne plus être pour personne je
pense que le problème à l'heure du jour
j'aurais pu vous inviter à aller à
l'aéroport et observer c'est lui que 21
et on parla même 2023 donc nous avons en
ce moment et les chars les chairs
légalement nous avons eu puis voir sur
le terrain les chairs également les
chars libyens les t54
il n'est malheureusement pas question à
n'djamena de filmer les libyens sous
peine d'être immédiatement emprisonné et
de se voir confisquer le matériel de
tournage et pourtant bien que discrète
on ne les voit que peu en ville les
troupes du colonel kadhafi sont bien là
sur les reports ou l'ancienne base
française comme elles sont présentes
dans tout le nord du tchad dans la bande
d'aozou bien sûr à l'extrême nord du
pays mais également à mao au nord-est du
lac tchad à bil in actie et abéché
au total 6000 à 7000 hommes selon les
responsables militaires tchadiens âme à
tabac le ministre de l'intérieur qui
assure en ce moment l'intérim du
président goukouni actuellement en libye
nous le confirme pour le moment tant que
la france essaie de nous entourer par
des forces entre le chat surtout dans
nos voisins
à mains des forces françaises alors chez
nos voisins ne pouvons pas nous
prononcer à n'importe que ce soit nous
gardons toujours les mêmes relations des
nac la librairie 4 et les forces c'est
didier qui sont enfin si vous aussi vous
êtes le carton ne pouvons pas nous
proposer
tant qu'il y aller mais nick est
derrière nous en passer pour moi de
sécurité il n'y a pas d'efforts s'ils
ligue 1 comme le temps fait il ya de
fortes pour nous aider pour mater la
rébellion et nous avons matériaux et
nous devons d'abord pour notre sécurité
à madaba et pro libyen il a sorti le mot
l'ennemi
pour lui l'ennemi c'est bien sûr cette
armée française basée en centrafrique
la position d'un mât tabac est partagé à
n'djamena par mamata si le ministre des
affaires étrangères tchadien également
pro libyen et par goukouni oueddei le
président du goon qui a réclamé
récemment à tripoli
aux côtés du colonel kadhafi le retrait
des troupes françaises d'afrique et
notamment de république centrafricaine
de son côté le vice-président du goon
chef des forces armées tchadiennes le
colonel kamougué se déclare prêt lui à
accepter une aide militaire de la france
au tchad en fait pour les sudistes
le danger ne vient pas de centrafrique
mais du nord du tchad
cette présence qui viennent au tchad et
le projet de mariage entre les deux pays
ne font pas du tout la frère de sudistes
qui n'en veulent pas
leur leader le colonel kamougué
vice-président du gouvernement d'union
nationale transitoire le crie haut et
fort dans son fief du sud non à la
fusion
oui au retrait des libyens
demeure encore convaincu que la libye se
vêtira que je reste convaincue qu'elle
se retire
si tel n'était pas le cas bien sûr
lappartient au peuple tchadien de se
déterminer par rapport à cet
envahissement cette espèce d'annexion de
nos pays au sud dans cette zone
méridionale qui n'a pas vécu la guerre
la psychose d'une annexion par la libye
s'est installée dans l'esprit de deux
millions et demi de sarah même si l'on
évite d'en parler très peu de la fusion
avec la libye le fort on en parle mais
en mal
la c30 pas de vivre avec lady d un
compte tenu de nos moeurs qui sont
diamétralement opposées
ici au sud la situation économique est
moins alarmante dans le nord du pays la
côte au tchad principales entreprises du
sud fait encore vivre aujourd'hui des
milliers de petits planteurs auquel elle
achète la récole mais avec une
production annuelle de 170 mille tonnes
en 1976
la récolte de cette année ne dépassera
pas les 80 mille tonnes conséquence de
la guerre au nord or d'un coton tchad
entreprises sudiste installé à moundou
siège du comité permanent du colonel
kamougué est un peu le trésor de guerre
du sud est son importance politique est
capital un affaiblissement prolongé de
sa production due à la disparition du
système bancaire par exemple aurait des
conséquences
incontestable sur l'avenir économique du
sud et par ricochet sur son leader le
colonel kamougué toutes les industries
qui existent au sud de jeux pan de ses
textiles ne pas l'exemple de la reprise
prend l'exemple de manufacture de tabac
vivent grâce à des actions monétaires
cas copains cadum aux paysans celle à
copenhague machette coûts du coton c'est
que les 2 6 2 6 4
ce pas
malgré ces difficultés ce sud est moins
pauvre et depuis toujours que le nord du
tchad mais comme le nord il ne pourra
pas s'en sortir seul
si personne ne l'aide à se remonter il
tombera par obligation et malgré le voeu
des sudistes
dans un premier temps sous la coupe
économique des libyens
en attendant la domination militaire des
troupes du colonel kadhafi
michel bembe ministre de l'économie du
gud et sudistes ne veut pas lui non plus
des libyens il préfère se tourner du
côté de l'occident pour demander de
l'aide
nous espérons qu'à partir d'un plan que
nous aurons mis en place que des pays
aussi bien que des organismes
internationaux puissent reprendre un
autre appel pour pouvoir redresser
l'économie de ce pays
à quel pays pensez vous pour vous aider
bien nous pensons naturellement à
l'occident et en particulier à la france
qui connaît mieux ce pays qu'ils
comprennent
relancer l'économie est avant tout le
système bancaire reconstruire un jam
aidé à rassurer les populations civiles
notamment celle de la capitale qui
s'étaient réfugiées de l'autre côté du
chari au nord du cameroun et qui
commencent timidement à regagner la
ville ce sont les objectifs prioritaires
de la coalition gouvernementale entre
les différentes tendances actuellement
au pouvoir au tchad et qui pour
l'instant sont au moins d'accord sur un
point la france n'est pas rejeter de
l'aide internationale dont le pays a
besoin et l'aurait même la possibilité
de figurer en bonne place pas ne pas le
temps d'une transition lors tout de
suite les pronostics du tiercé demain à
vincennes le 16 le 18 le 8 le 14 le 2e
cat pardon est de 12
je ne m'aventurerai pas un pronostic
pour france irlande demain au rugby la
seule certitude c'est qu'on y battre un
record celui des sélections pour un seul
homme bertranne 64 fois sous le maillot
de l'équipe de france dépasse en effet
le vieux record de benoît dauga ganil
cazals nous présente les verts et les
bleus cet exercice à la presse oblique
daniel revallier l'a répété dix fois au
cours de la même séance de musculation
si bien qu'il aura au total soulevé
l'équivalent du pack irlandais demain à
dublin daniel revallier et les abats
français auront besoin de toutes leurs
forces pour tenir 80 minutes ce qui ne
fut pas le cas face à l'ecosse il ya
trois semaines c'est irlande france sera
la 54e rencontre entre les deux pays au
palmarès général les français mènent
d'une seule victoire 25 contre 24 et
quatre matches nuls pour que demain soir
les deux pays ne soit pas totalement à
égalité à l'issue de la rencontre
les français n'ont négligé aucun détail
ils se sont entraînés avec un ballon
britannique légèrement différent du
modèle français dans cette équipe de
france il y aura un nouveau deal apporte
28 en 2000 ouverture un coup de pied qui
sera très précieux lui aussi toute la
semaine il a travaillé avec un ballon
pour pourrait qualifier d'historique
tanner qui on a prêté gentiment votes
espagne on était beaucoup plus pointue
aux frais mois ne se fasse que la france
est donc qu'ils ont pour ne pas être
familiarisé jeu préféré m'entraîner quoi
enfin s'il y aura aussi un superbe
auteurs holy campbell surnommé monsieur
65% depuis qu'il a marqué à lui seul 46
des 70 points réussie l'an dernier par
l'irlande 46 points dans un tournoi
c'est un record depuis la cuillère de
bois de 1977 les irlandais sont en gros
progrès quatrième en 78 troisième en 79
ils ont terminé deuxièmes derrière
l'angleterre l'année dernière cette
année ils savent qu'ils peuvent gagner
le tournoi
leur volonté et leur détermination sont
légendaires il ne s'avoue jamais vaincu
il ya un an au parc des princes ils ont
été battus d'un seul point après avoir
été menés 19 à 9 ce jour-là mclennan
avait donné le signal de la charge de
cette équipe les irlandais ont conservé
dix des quinze joueurs demain le vieux
stade de lansdowne road sera plein à
craquer il y aura cependant des absents
de marque pour la première fois les
hommes politiques irlandais boycotteront
le tournoi pour protester contre la
décision de la fédération irlandaise
d'effectuer une tournée en afrique du
sud à la fin de la saison alors l'arc en
ciel nous fournit la transition laurent
broomhead pas vraiment la carrure de
revallier mais des bons pronostics pour
il parle quand catastrophe pour la
méthode ce week end les nuages et les
pluies des filets la hauteur des îles
britanniques chez nous beaucoup de
nuages plus au nord que dans le sud et
partout la douceur alors la carte pour
demain et bien dans l'extrême nord-est
du pays il fera d'abord froid le matin
avec de la brume et très vite le redoux
était nuages arriveront vous les voyez
ici le giron jusqu'au nord des alpes et
du massif central
pendant une grande partie du pays
partout ailleurs et bien là encore des
nuages mais cette fois sans aucun risque
de puteaux rythmant et quelques éclats
c'est également plus belle dans la
moitié sud du pays enfin un mot du temps
de dimanche est bien théoriquement des
nuages dans nord beaucoup de nuages un
peu de pluie dans l'est le matin et dans
l'ouest le soir et puis dans la moitié
sud nuages et soleil soleil pardon se
partageront le ciel avec toujours la
douceur bien tout est en train de
programmes du patineur
artistique auparavant le journal vous
sera présentée par patricia charnolé à
22h50 demain l'invité d'un thème 2010
sera michel galabru et à 20 heures une
grande première c'est patricia chars ne
l'est que vous retrouverez pour ce
journal de 20 heures tous nos voeux
l'accompagnent
à bientôt